Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on CaseFiles Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and ad-free, you can support case file on your preferred platform.
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。本剧集最初是在CaseFiles Patreon、Apple Premium和Spotify Premium订阅源上发布的，作为我们付费订阅者的早期福利。这些剧集旨在稍微缩短，使我们能够涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前且无广告地收听这些剧集，您可以在您首选的平台上支持CaseFile。
Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. On Saturday, May 5, 1979, a shout rang out over the bustling Plaza Urbina. Market Square in the Ecuadorian city of Ambato. Alarming disappearance of Ecuadorian girls continues. The day's newspaper headline was met with dread from passing locals. For several months, girls between the ages of 7 and 14 had been vanishing from the streets of Ecuador. A majority of them worked as market vendors, having come from poor families who required them to sell goods to help make ends. meet. Because of this, the police mostly branded the girls as runaways. Some officers believed
今天的剧集涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。1979年5月5日星期六，厄瓜多尔安巴托市繁华的乌尔比纳广场（Plaza Urbina）市场上传出一声呼喊。“厄瓜多尔女孩失踪事件持续令人担忧。”当天的报纸头条让路过的当地人感到恐惧。几个月来，7到14岁的女孩不断从厄瓜多尔的街头消失。她们中的大多数人是市场摊贩，来自贫困家庭，需要卖货来维持生计。正因如此，警方大多将这些女孩定性为离家出走。一些警官认为
the girls had fled to bigger cities where they could get jobs as maids. They told worried parents that their daughters were now probably better off. Others suggested the girls had fled their homes out of shame for failing their school year. Despite being aware of the ever-increasing danger, many parents couldn't afford to hide their daughters away. All they could do was keep a closer eye on their children and warn them not to go off with strangers. It wasn't enough. Each week across the country, two to three girls continued to go missing. At Plaza Urbina, 11-year-old Ortencia Garcés held a stack of the newspapers while shouting the horrifying headline, trying to catch the interest of passes by.
这些女孩逃到了大城市，可以在那里找到女佣的工作。他们告诉忧心忡忡的父母，她们现在可能过得更好。其他人则认为，这些女孩是因为学业失败感到羞愧而离家出走。尽管意识到危险日益增加，许多父母却无力将女儿藏起来。他们唯一能做的就是更密切地关注孩子，并警告她们不要跟陌生人走。但这还不够。每周全国各地仍有两到三名女孩失踪。在乌尔比纳广场，11岁的奥滕西亚·加塞斯（Ortencia Garcés）一边拿着一叠报纸，一边大声喊着那令人毛骨悚然的头条新闻，试图引起路人的注意。
For Ortencia, selling newspapers was a necessity. She was about to become a big sister and had to help her family provide for the arrival of her brother. Ortencia continued shouting as she left Plaza Robina and weaved her way through the city's street. That evening, as Darkness set in, Ortencia's family began to worry. Ortencia should have sold all of the city's. of her newspapers hours ago, but she still hadn't returned home. Fearing the worst, Ortencia's
对奥滕西亚来说，卖报纸是必需的。她即将成为姐姐，必须帮助家庭为弟弟的到来做准备。奥滕西亚离开乌尔比纳广场，穿过城市街道时继续叫卖。那天晚上，随着夜幕降临，奥滕西亚的家人开始担心起来。奥滕西亚本应在几小时前就卖完所有的报纸，但她仍未回家。出于最坏的打算，奥滕西亚的
father ran to Plaza Robina. There was no sign of the 11-year-old anywhere. Three days later, the Tuesday edition of the newspaper was released. The headline revealed that Ortencia Garcese was the latest girl to go missing without a trace. Over the next nine months, an increasing number of young Ecuadorian girls continued to go missing. Investigators could no longer ignore the issue. When they finally started looking into the string of disappearances, a distinct geographical pattern emerged. The towns and cities from where the girls had vanished were concentrated along the Andes mountain range. The northernmost town sat right up against the border with Colombia, while the southernmost town was near the border with Peru.
父亲跑向乌尔比纳广场。到处都没有这个11岁女孩的踪影。三天后，周二版的报纸发布了。头条新闻显示，奥滕西亚·加塞斯是最新一个失踪且毫无踪迹的女孩。在接下来的九个月里，越来越多的厄瓜多尔年轻女孩持续失踪。调查人员再也无法忽视这个问题。当他们最终开始调查这一连串的失踪事件时，一个明显的地理模式出现了。女孩们失踪的城镇和城市都集中在安第斯山脉沿线。最北端的城镇紧邻哥伦比亚边境，而最南端的城镇则靠近秘鲁边境。
To police, this strongly suggested the involvement of human traffickers. They theorised that the girls were being hidden in vehicles, funneled along the Andes ranges and smuggled across the borders. The only city not positioned along the Andes was Waiaquil, which sat about 100 kilometres west of the mountains. What disturbed the city to the city? The police about this deviation was that Waiakil was a port city. It handled over 90% of the country's shipping container traffic.
对警方来说，这强烈暗示了人口贩运者的参与。他们推测，女孩们被藏在车辆中，沿着安第斯山脉输送并走私过境。唯一不在安第斯山脉沿线的城市是瓜亚基尔（Guayaquil），它位于山脉以西约100公里处。让警方对这一偏差感到困扰的是，瓜亚基尔是一个港口城市。它处理了全国90%以上的集装箱运输业务。
Police feared that the girls were being loaded into these containers and transported by sea. Drug trafficking by Colombian gangs had been an increasing problem, and the theory quickly emerged that the criminals had expanded into child trafficking. National newspapers reported that the Colombian. The Colombians had recruited a network of on-the-ground members from within Ecuador to procure young girls from the streets. They were most likely being transported to another country in South or Central America and sold into domestic or sexual slavery.
警方担心女孩们被装进这些集装箱并通过海路运输。哥伦比亚帮派的毒品走私一直是一个日益严重的问题，很快就出现了犯罪分子已扩展到人口贩运的理论。全国性报纸报道称，哥伦比亚人已经在厄瓜多尔内部招募了一个地面成员网络，从街头诱拐年轻女孩。她们很可能被运往南美或中美洲的另一个国家，并被卖为家庭奴隶或性奴隶。
International child trafficking was a problem that had plagued South America for decades, but Ecuador had rarely seen it on such an enormous scale. were on edge. It was well known that members of trafficking organisations weren't limited to the obvious criminal types. Anyone could be involved, from business owners to factory workers, local officials, and teachers. The fact that the girls had been taken without anyone noticing suggested that the abductors could easily blend in with their communities. People became increasingly suspicious of their neighbours. Across the country, police commenced a coordinated effort to capture anyone involved in the trafficking ring. Officers were posted at airports and bus terminals to identify any suspicious activity.
国际人口贩运是困扰南美洲几十年的问题，但厄瓜多尔很少见到如此大规模的贩运。人们感到不安。众所周知，贩运组织的成员并不局限于明显的犯罪分子。任何人都有可能参与其中，从企业主到工厂工人、地方官员和教师。女孩们在无人察觉的情况下被带走，这表明绑架者可以轻易地融入他们的社区。人们对邻居变得越来越怀疑。全国各地的警察开始协调行动，抓捕任何参与贩运团伙的人。警官被派往机场和巴士总站，以识别任何可疑活动。
Every truck, van and car attempting to cross the border into Colombia or Peru was thoroughly searched. Uniformed officers were stationed in marketplaces to provide a visible police presence, while undercover officers covertly patrolled these areas, posing as market vendors or customers. Round-the-clock surveillance teams watched the docks in Wayakil, keeping an eye on all of the containers leaving Ecuador. Undercover officers posed as dock workers in the hopes of gaining intel about human cargo. Despite these actions, not a single missing girl was located, nor a single suspect detained. The fact that the police were being continuously outsmarted suggested that the trafficking ring was being run by highly skilled and highly organised criminals.
每一辆试图越过边境进入哥伦比亚或秘鲁的卡车、货车和轿车都经过了彻底搜查。身穿制服的警官驻扎在市场中以提供可见的警力，而便衣警官则秘密巡逻这些区域，伪装成市场摊贩或顾客。全天候监控小组监视着瓜亚基尔的码头，留意所有离开厄瓜多尔的集装箱。便衣警官伪装成码头工人，希望能获得有关“人体货物”的情报。尽管采取了这些行动，但没有找到一名失踪女孩，也没有拘留一名嫌疑人。警方不断被智取的事实表明，该贩运团伙是由技术高超且组织严密的犯罪分子经营的。
By early 1980, 150 girls between the ages of 7 and 14 had been reported missing along the Andes ranges. The situation was labelled a national crisis. As tensions heightened, the country's president demanded that the police produce results. Umbatos police captain, Pastor Cordova, sat at his desk in contemplation. The disappearance of 11-year-old Ortencia Garcese from Plaza Rubina nine months earlier wasn't the first in his jurisdiction. Nearly a dozen girls had been stolen from Ambato on Captain Cordova's watch.
到1980年初，安第斯山脉沿线已有150名7至14岁的女孩被报告失踪。这种情况被称为国家危机。随着紧张局势加剧，国家总统要求警方拿出成果。安巴托的警察队长帕斯托·科尔多瓦（Pastor Cordova）坐在办公桌前沉思。九个月前11岁的奥滕西亚·加塞斯从乌尔比纳广场失踪，这并不是他管辖区内的第一起案件。在科尔多瓦队长的监督下，安巴托已有近十几名女孩被绑架。
Frustrated and unsure what else to do, Captain Cordova began reviewing the rap sheet of Colombian criminals with known links to trafficking or other organised crime. Perhaps his officers would get lucky and catch sight of one of these Colombians in Arbato. With the right interrogation tactics, they could use this one gang member to break open the entire trafficking operation. The captain prayed to find one of these men before another girl went missing. On the afternoon of Thursday, February 14, 1980, a well-respected bakery owner named Carlos Yakome entered the Ambato Police Station and stood before Captain Cordova. Carlos was in obvious distress.
感到沮丧且不知所措的科尔多瓦队长开始审查那些与贩运或其他有组织犯罪有已知联系的哥伦比亚罪犯的犯罪记录。也许他的警官会走运，在安巴托发现其中一名哥伦比亚人。通过正确的审讯策略，他们可以利用这个帮派成员来破获整个贩运行动。队长祈祷在另一个女孩失踪之前找到这些人。1980年2月14日星期四下午，一位受人尊敬的面包店老板卡洛斯·雅科梅（Carlos Yakome）走进安巴托警察局，站在科尔多瓦队长面前。卡洛斯显然非常痛苦。
He explained that his nine-year-old daughter, Eva Nova, sometimes brought food to him at the bakery's head office. She usually arrived by 11 a.m., but on this day, she didn't tell her. turn up. Carlos went home to check that everything was okay, only to find that the house was empty. He and his wife searched for Ivanova but couldn't find her anywhere. Captain Cordova considered what Carlos had just told him. Ivanova Yakome was within the preferred age range of the child traffickers, but she didn't fit with the rest of their usual victim profile. Ivanova belonged to a wealthy family and didn't work as a market vendor.
他解释说，他九岁的女儿伊万诺娃（Ivanova）有时会给面包店总部送食物。她通常在上午11点到达，但今天她没有出现。卡洛斯回家检查一切是否正常，却发现房子里空无一人。他和妻子寻找伊万诺娃，但到处都找不到她。科尔多瓦队长考虑了卡洛斯刚才告诉他的话。伊万诺娃·雅科梅处于儿童贩运者偏好的年龄范围内，但她并不符合他们通常的受害者特征。伊万诺娃属于富裕家庭，并不在市场做摊贩。
Captain Cordova asked whether Ivanova's route would have taken her anywhere near Plaza Robina. Carlos nodded. The Yakomé family home was right near the plaza. Officers immediately began canvassing the streets between the Yakomis home and the Bakery's head office, asking if anyone had seen a Yacomai. young girl wearing blue overalls and a red apron with white poker dots. Carlos and his wife pinned hundreds of missing person posters featuring a smiling picture of Ivanova to street lamps and shop windows across Ambatto, offering a substantial cash reward for information. The investigation turned up nothing. Police couldn't even be certain
科尔多瓦队长询问伊万诺娃的路线是否会经过乌尔比纳广场附近。卡洛斯点了点头。雅科梅一家住在广场附近。警官们立即开始在雅科梅家和面包店总部之间的街道上进行排查，询问是否有人见过一个穿着蓝色工装裤、戴着红色波点围裙的年轻女孩。卡洛斯和他的妻子在安巴托各处的路灯和商店橱窗上张贴了数百张印有伊万诺娃微笑照片的寻人启事，并提供丰厚的现金奖励以获取信息。调查一无所获。警方甚至无法确定
where along the route Ivanova had been abducted. Three weeks after Ivanova had been abducted, three weeks after even over's disappearance on the morning of Sunday, March 9, 1980, Plaza Robina's market vendors huddled together before opening time. Carlina Ramon, who ran the hot potato stall and was the president of the Sellers Association, reminded the group that several young girls who worked in or near the plaza had fallen victim to the child trafficking gang. She urged everyone to be on the lookout for anything suspicious. Those in the crowd nodded in agreement before dispersing towards their stalls. Carlina called over her 11-year-old daughter Maria, who would be manning a refreshment stand in the plaza that day.
伊万诺娃是在路线上的哪个位置被绑架的。在伊万诺娃失踪三周后，1980年3月9日星期日上午，乌尔比纳广场的市场摊贩在开市前聚在一起。经营烤土豆摊位并担任摊贩协会主席的卡琳娜·拉蒙（Carlina Ramon）提醒大家，几名在广场内或附近工作的年轻女孩已经成为儿童贩运团伙的受害者。她敦促大家留意任何可疑情况。人群点头表示同意，然后散开前往各自的摊位。卡琳娜叫来了她11岁的女儿玛丽亚（Maria），她那天将在广场的茶点摊工作。
Carlina embraced Maria and implored her to be extra careful. Maria skipped over to her stall and prepared for the day ahead. Her friend Astor, not her real name, was also working at a reference. freshman stand nearby, and the two girls promised to look out for one another. The crowds soon poured in, and by 10 a.m., Plaza Rabina was buzzing with activity. Maria looked up as a tall, thin man with wavy brown hair and a toothless smile approached her stand. He was carrying a jumbled collection of trinkets, including buttons, sewing kits, matches, chains, padlocks, sweets and cosmetics.
卡琳娜拥抱了玛丽亚，恳求她格外小心。玛丽亚跳着跑向她的摊位，为即将到来的一天做准备。她的朋友埃丝特（Astor，化名）也在附近的茶点摊工作，两个女孩承诺会互相照应。人群很快涌入，到上午10点，乌尔比纳广场已是人声鼎沸。玛丽亚抬头看到一个身材高瘦、留着波浪形棕色头发、露着缺牙笑容的男人走近她的摊位。他带着一堆杂乱的小饰品，包括纽扣、缝纫工具、火柴、链子、挂锁、糖果和化妆品。
The man pulled out a crumpled 100 sucre bill and offered it to Maria. It was a significant amount of money and much more than any of the drinks cost. Maria eyed the man suspiciously. He explained that he was a travelling street vendor who was only passing through town. He needed help finding a bad. bus that would take him to weigh a kill. The man offered to pay Maria the 100 sucres if she took him to the bus stop. Maria declined, telling the man she couldn't leave her stand.
男人掏出一张皱巴巴的100苏克雷纸币递给玛丽亚。这是一笔不小的数目，远超过任何饮料的价格。玛丽亚怀疑地看着这个男人。他解释说他是一个路过的流动小贩。他需要帮助找一辆能带他去瓜亚基尔的巴士。男人提出如果玛丽亚带他去巴士站，就给她100苏克雷。玛丽亚拒绝了，告诉男人她不能离开摊位。
He turned and wandered away. Maria called to her friend Esther and explained the strange encounter. They decided it was best to tell Maria's mother, Carlina, and dashed over to her store. Carlina followed Maria back to the refreshment stand to see if the suspicious man was still loitering. They scanned the surrounding faces, but he disappeared into the crowd. A few hours later, as the day's trade began to quieten down, the street vendor reappeared. This time he approached Esther's refreshment stand. He repeated the story that he'd told Maria earlier, offering Esther the way.
他转身走开了。玛丽亚叫来她的朋友埃丝特，解释了刚才奇怪的遭遇。她们决定最好告诉玛丽亚的母亲卡琳娜，于是冲向她的摊位。卡琳娜跟着玛丽亚回到茶点摊，看看那个可疑的男人是否还在徘徊。她们扫描了周围的面孔，但他已经消失在人群中。几个小时后，当白天的生意开始平静下来时，那个小贩又出现了。这次他走向了埃丝特的茶点摊。他重复了之前告诉玛丽亚的故事，提出给埃丝特
100 sucreys to be his guide. He also offered to buy all of Esther's remaining drinks so that she wouldn't lose out on any money by leaving her stall unattended. Esther was immediately mistrustful. She snapped back. Why do you just ask little girls? Why not ask an adult, a man? Without waiting for his response, Esther grabbed Maria and they hurried to find Carlin. Carlina. Carlyna immediately sprung into action. She dashed over to where the girls had last seen the man, but he hadn't waited around. Carlina quickly enlisted the help of other Vandors, and they spread themselves throughout the plaza on the hunt for the tall, toothless man carrying a collection of trinkets. Carlina charged through the labyrinth of stalls until she was certain the whole market
100苏克雷作为向导费。他还提出买下埃丝特剩下的所有饮料，这样她就不会因为离开摊位而损失钱财。埃丝特立刻产生了怀疑。她反驳道：“你为什么只问小女孩？为什么不问成年人，问个男人？”没等他回答，埃丝特拉起玛丽亚匆忙去找卡琳娜。卡琳娜立即采取行动。她冲向女孩们最后一次见到那个男人的地方，但他并没有停留。卡琳娜迅速寻求其他摊贩的帮助，他们分散在广场各处，搜寻那个带着一堆小饰品、缺牙的高个子男人。卡琳娜穿过摊位迷宫，直到她确信整个市场
had been canvassed. Frustrated that he'd managed to escape again, Carlina stopped on the edge of the plaza to catch her breath. Just as she was about to return to her potato stand, she spotted someone who fit the description of the man coming out of a butcher's shop across the street. One of his abnormally large hands was wrapped around the tiny hand of a nine-year-old girl. He was leading her away from the plaza.
都已被搜查过。因为没能抓住他而感到沮丧，卡琳娜停在广场边缘喘口气。就在她准备回到土豆摊时，她看到一个符合描述的男人从街对面的肉铺里走出来。他那只异常大的手正紧紧抓着一个九岁女孩的小手。他正带着她离开广场。
Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Carlina began screaming that the man was kidnapping a child. She ran over to him and grabbed his arm. The man tried to wriggle out of Carina's grasp, but she held onto him with all her stress.
Case File稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供优质内容。卡琳娜开始尖叫，说那个男人在绑架孩子。她跑向他并抓住他的手臂。男人试图从卡琳娜的抓握中挣脱，但她用尽全力紧紧抓住他，
strength, continuing to shout for assistance. Within seconds, nearly a dozen men pounced on the trinket vendor and held him securely. Realising he couldn't escape, the man stopped struggling. He offered the crowd a toothless smile, saying he was just a simple travelling street vendor trying to make a living. He claimed that the young girl was merely showing him the way to the bus station so he could continue his journey. To some of the men, this explanation seemed entirely plausible. Thinking they may have reacted unfairly, they relaxed their grip. But Carlina didn't believe a word of it.
继续大声呼救。几秒钟内，近十几名男子扑向那个小贩并将他牢牢控制住。意识到无法逃脱，男人停止了挣扎。他向人群露出了缺牙的笑容，说他只是一个试图谋生的简单流动小贩。他声称那个小女孩只是在给他指去巴士站的路，以便他继续旅程。对一些人来说，这个解释似乎完全合理。他们认为自己可能反应过度了，于是放松了抓握。但卡琳娜一个字也不信。
She told the crowd that the trinket seller was part of the trafficking ring abducting and selling young girls. He'd earlier tried to lure her own daughter away with money. Those in front could see that the confused nine-year-old girl from the butcher's shop was grasping a crumpled 100-sucre bill. The crowd was torn. Some supported Carlina while others thought she was being hysterical. As calls to let the man go began to circulate, police arrived on the scene and took him into custody. When Ambato's police captain, Pastor Cordova, entered the interrogation room, he was furious. The detaining officers had tried to extract information from the trinket vendor with violence,
她告诉人群，这个小贩是绑架和贩卖年轻女孩的贩运团伙的一员。他早些时候曾试图用钱诱骗她自己的女儿。前面的人可以看到，那个来自肉铺、神情困惑的九岁女孩手里正抓着一张皱巴巴的100苏克雷纸币。人群产生了分歧。一些人支持卡琳娜，而另一些人认为她歇斯底里。当要求放人的呼声开始流传时，警察赶到现场并将他拘留。当安巴托的警察队长帕斯托·科尔多瓦走进审讯室时，他非常愤怒。拘留警官曾试图用暴力从这个小贩那里获取信息，
and he sat bruised and bloody. The beatings hadn't achieved anything. The man insisted he was innocent and knew nothing about the alleged trafficking ring. Captain Cordova feared that the officers had squandered any chance, to get information from the suspect. Instead, he decided to approach with kindness. Captain Cordova brought the man a drink and a sandwich and offered him a cigarette.
他坐在那里，浑身青肿且带着血迹。殴打没有任何效果。男人坚称自己是无辜的，对所谓的贩运团伙一无所知。科尔多瓦队长担心警官们浪费了从嫌疑人那里获取信息的任何机会。相反，他决定以善意对待。科尔多瓦队长给男人拿来饮料和三明治，并递给他一支烟。
The two sat smoking together in silence. Eventually, Captain Cordova assured the Trinket Vendor that he wouldn't receive any more beatings and asked if the two could just talk for a while. The man nodded in agreement. He said his name was Pedro Alonzo Lopez, and he was a 31-year-old travelling vendor from Columbia. The captain maintained a calm exterior, but internally he was excited, thinking he may have finally caught one of the Colombian gang members.
两人坐在一起默默地抽烟。最终，科尔多瓦队长向小贩保证他不会再受到殴打，并询问两人是否可以聊一会儿。男人点头表示同意。他说他的名字叫佩德罗·阿隆索·洛佩斯（Pedro Alonzo Lopez），是一名来自哥伦比亚的31岁流动小贩。队长保持着冷静的外表，但内心却很兴奋，认为他可能终于抓住了其中一名哥伦比亚帮派成员。
Cordova leaned in a little further and said, Tell me about yourself. Lopez relaxed and started to talk. Captain Cordova desperately wanted to ask about the missing girls, but he didn't want to jump into the subject too soon. Instead, he asked Lopez whether he had a criminal past. Lopez admitted that when he was 21, he was caught stealing a car in Borgata, the capital city of Columbia.
科尔多瓦警长又凑近了一些，说道：“跟我说说你自己吧。”洛佩兹放松下来，开始讲述。科尔多瓦警长非常想询问失踪女孩的事，但他不想太快切入主题。相反，他问洛佩兹是否有犯罪前科。洛佩兹承认，他21岁时因在哥伦比亚首都波哥大偷车被捕。
He was sent to prison for seven years. One night, four older men entered his cell and raped him. Lopez swore revenge. Two weeks later, he lured each of the men one by one back into his cell. He stabbed three of them to death with a makeshift knife. The fourth managed to escape and raised the alarm. The authorities considered the killings to be in self-defense, and Lopez wasn't harsh. punished. Since his release, Lopez made his meager living as a travelling street vendor.
他被判入狱七年。一天晚上，四名年长的囚犯闯入他的牢房强奸了他。洛佩兹发誓要报复。两周后，他将这些人一个接一个地诱骗回自己的牢房。他用一把自制的刀刺死了其中三人。第四个人设法逃脱并拉响了警报。当局认为这些杀戮属于正当防卫，洛佩兹没有受到严厉惩罚。出狱后，洛佩兹靠做流动小贩维持微薄的生计。
He told Captain Cordova that he liked to be continuously on the move between Columbia, Ecuador and Peru. Recognising this as an opportunity, the captain suggested to Lopez that a man who travelled so much must have seen many things. Lopez agreed. Captain Cordova pushed. So you must know about the traffickers of the little girls. Lopez shook his head. He said he didn't know anything about traffickers and wasn't involved with that sort of thing at all. Lopez then gave the captain a broad, toothless smile and said, But, I do know about the girls. Lopez said the police should forget about chasing down a child trafficking ring.
他告诉科尔多瓦警长，他喜欢在哥伦比亚、厄瓜多尔和秘鲁之间不断奔波。警长认为这是一个机会，便向洛佩兹暗示，一个走南闯北的人一定见过很多世面。洛佩兹表示同意。科尔多瓦警长乘胜追击：“那你一定知道那些拐卖小女孩的人贩子。”洛佩兹摇了摇头。他说他不知道人贩子的事，也根本没有参与过那种勾当。随后，洛佩兹向警长露出了一个灿烂的、没牙的微笑，说道：“不过，我确实知道那些女孩的事。”洛佩兹说，警方应该放弃追查儿童贩卖团伙。
He said there was only one person responsible for the missing girls. And that person was him. Captain Cordova was unconvinced. Over 150 girls had been reported missing over the past year and it wasn't possible that one man had kidnapped them all. Furthermore, if Pedro Lopez really was responsible, selling the girls would have earned him a lot of money. The man sitting before him was near penniless.
他说，对女孩失踪负责的只有一个人，那个人就是他。科尔多瓦警长并不相信。过去一年里有超过150名女孩失踪，一个人不可能绑架了所有人。此外，如果佩德罗·洛佩兹真的要负责，贩卖女孩本应让他赚很多钱，但坐在他面前的这个人几乎身无分文。
Regardless, the captain did believe Lopez knew something about what had happened to the missing girls. He asked, Where are the girls now? Lopez laughed and spoke triumphantly. They are all dead, dead and buried along the Andes. He flashed another toothless grin and continued. I'll show you. Within the hour, Captain Cordova and two other officers were in a police car following Lopez's directions.
无论如何，警长确实相信洛佩兹知道失踪女孩的下落。他问道：“女孩们现在在哪里？”洛佩兹大笑起来，得意洋洋地说：“她们都死了，死后被埋在安第斯山脉沿线。”他再次露出没牙的笑容，继续说道：“我会带你们去。”一小时内，科尔多瓦警长和其他两名警官坐上警车，跟随洛佩兹的指引出发了。
They drove north out of Ambato for about 16 kilometres and until they reached a rural farming area. Lopez directed the police through a number of turns down nondescripted dirt roads until he finally signalled for the car to stop. Cordova and his officers followed Lopez on foot through scrub until they came to a gap in a fence. Lopez slipped through and ran ahead. When the officers caught up, Lopez was standing in front of a small wooden box. It was roughly 130 centimetres long and 90 centimetres wide and looked like it was intended to be a makeshift beehive.
他们从安巴托向北行驶了约16公里，直到到达一个农村农业区。洛佩兹指挥警察在几条不起眼的土路上转了几个弯，最后示意停车。科尔多瓦和他的警官们步行跟随洛佩兹穿过灌木丛，直到来到栅栏的一个缺口处。洛佩兹钻了过去，跑在前面。当警官们追上时，洛佩兹正站在一个木箱前。它长约130厘米，宽约90厘米，看起来像是一个简易的蜂箱。
A stanch hung in the air as Lopez pointed to the box. The officers used crowbars to crack open the lid. Inside was a dirty mattress. On top of the mattress was the naked body of a young girl. Captain Cordova immediately knew who she was. Tucked alongside her body was a pair of blue overalls and a red apron with white poker dots. It was 9-year-old Ivanova Yakome. Investigators had assumed that Ivanova had been abducted while walking to deliver food to her father,
当洛佩兹指向那个箱子时，空气中弥漫着一股恶臭。警官们用撬棍撬开了盖子。里面是一张脏兮兮的床垫。床垫上躺着一具年轻女孩的赤裸尸体。科尔多瓦警长立刻认出了她是谁。在她的尸体旁塞着一件蓝色工作服和一条带有白色波点的红色围裙。她是9岁的伊万诺娃·雅科梅。调查人员此前推测伊万诺娃是在给父亲送饭的路上被绑架的，
but according to Lopez, that wasn't the case. He explained that on the morning of the morning of the day. Thursday, February 14, 1980, he was passing by the Yakomé's house when Eva Nova poked her head outside the front door. She looked up the street before retreating back inside. Lopez stopped in his tracks. He watched the house for a few hours until he was certain that the child was home alone. Lopez eventually knocked on the front door, but there was no answer. He called out. He called out, to Ivanova, saying he was a friend of her father's. Ivanova cautiously opened the door.
但据洛佩兹说，事实并非如此。他解释说，1980年2月14日星期四那天早上，他路过雅科梅家时，伊万诺娃探出头来。她看了看街上，然后退回屋里。洛佩兹停下脚步。他观察了这所房子几个小时，直到确定孩子独自在家。洛佩兹最终敲了前门，但没有人应答。他喊道，他喊伊万诺娃的名字，说他是她父亲的朋友。伊万诺娃小心翼翼地打开了门。
Lopez produced ten sucreys and said that Ivanova's parents wanted them to go to the store to buy vegetables. Ivanova was hesitant, but Lopez said that her parents would be angry if she didn't go with him. She took Lopez's hand and the pair walked down the street. Lopez spoke to Eva Nova sweetly and distracted her with conversation. He guided her out of Ambato and towards the rural countryside. After several hours, they were amongst farmlands.
洛佩兹拿出十苏克雷，说伊万诺娃的父母想让他们去商店买蔬菜。伊万诺娃很犹豫，但洛佩兹说如果她不跟他去，她的父母会生气的。她牵起洛佩兹的手，两人沿着街道走去。洛佩兹甜言蜜语地哄着伊万诺娃，用谈话分散她的注意力。他把她带出了安巴托，朝农村地区走去。几个小时后，他们来到了农田之中。
By nightfall, Ivanova became tired of walking and started asking for her mother. Lopez looked around and spotted the wooden box plus a discarded mattress lying nearby. He opened the box and placed the mattress inside. All of his friendliness towards Ivanova disappeared, and he ordered her to climb inside. Lopez subdued Ivanova by punching her twice in the head. He then raped her repeatedly before strangling her to death. Lopez slept alongside her body for a while, before closing the lid of the box and walking away. Captain Pastor Cordova made the heartbreaking call to Ivanova's parents.
天黑时，伊万诺娃走累了，开始吵着要找妈妈。洛佩兹环顾四周，发现了那个木箱和附近丢弃的床垫。他打开箱子，把床垫放进去。他对伊万诺娃的所有友善瞬间消失，他命令她爬进去。洛佩兹猛击伊万诺娃头部两次将她制服。随后，他多次强奸了她，然后将她勒死。洛佩兹在她的尸体旁睡了一会儿，然后关上箱盖走开了。帕斯托·科尔多瓦警长给伊万诺娃的父母打了那个令人心碎的电话。
When Carlos Yakomei saw his daughter's body, he was unable to speak. Ivanova's mother collapsed to the floor. An autopsy on Ivanova's body later corroborated Lopez's account of his attack. Lopez had more to say. He was eager to take police to take police to. another of his young victims. As they prepared to depart the station, they were met by an angry mob, baying for Lopez's blood. Captain Cordova tried to appease the crowd, telling them he understood their anger, but this wasn't just about even over. There were many
当卡洛斯·雅科梅看到女儿的尸体时，他无法言语。伊万诺娃的母亲瘫倒在地。随后对伊万诺娃尸体的尸检证实了洛佩兹的供述。洛佩兹还有更多话要说。他急于带警察去寻找他的另一名年轻受害者。当他们准备离开警局时，遇到了一群愤怒的暴徒，他们高喊着要洛佩兹偿命。科尔多瓦警长试图安抚人群，告诉他们他理解他们的愤怒，但这不仅仅是伊万诺娃一个人的事。还有许多
more missing girls to be found. The crowd ignored the captain's pleas to be patient and repeatedly called for Lopez to be lynched. Officers were forced to smuggle Lopez through an alternative exit and bundle him into a waiting police vehicle. This time, they didn't have to travel far. Pedro Lopez directed police to the outskirts of town, where the Fikawa Bridge connected central Umbato with the affluent neighborhood of Fikawa. He specified a site underneath the bridge on the banks of the Ambato River. Officers began digging, and it wasn't long before they found something buried underneath. It was a stack of newspapers dated May 5, 1979, the day that 11-year-old Ortencia Garces had disappeared.
失踪女孩有待寻找。人群无视警长保持耐心的请求，反复要求对洛佩兹私刑处死。警官们被迫将洛佩兹从另一个出口带走，并把他塞进一辆等候的警车里。这一次，他们没走多远。佩德罗·洛佩兹指挥警察来到城郊，那里有一座菲卡瓦大桥，连接着安巴托市中心和富裕的菲卡瓦社区。他指定了桥下安巴托河岸边的一个地点。警官们开始挖掘，没过多久就发现了埋在下面的东西。那是一叠日期为1979年5月5日的报纸，正是11岁的奥滕西亚·加塞斯失踪的那一天。
Underneath the papers was a small set of skeletal remains. News that a second body had been uncovered quickly spread and humphed. Hundreds of townsfolk gathered on the scene. As the remains were lifted out of the dirt, Captain Cordova spotted Ortencia's parents in the crowd and brought them forward. The body was too badly decomposed to be identified, but Ortencia's parents recognized her clothes. The angry crowd began throwing rocks at Lopez,
报纸下面是一具小小的骸骨。第二具尸体被发现的消息迅速传开，数百名镇民聚集在现场。当遗骸从土里被抬出来时，科尔多瓦警长在人群中发现了奥滕西亚的父母，并把他们带到前面。尸体腐烂严重，无法辨认，但奥滕西亚的父母认出了她的衣服。愤怒的人群开始向洛佩兹投掷石块，
forcing police to remove him from the scene. On their way back to the station, Lopez confessed that he'd approached Ortencia Garces as she was crossing the Fokowa Bridge. He took a copy of the newspaper and made a comment about the missing girls headline. He then asked Ortencia to be his guide, offering to pay ten sucres as well as by all of her remaining papers. Ortencia agreed. Lopez led Ortencia into the thick vegetation of the riverbank, where he proceeded to repeatedly rape her before strangling her to death. He rested alongside Ortencia's corpse for a few hours, then buried her and her newspapers in a nearby
迫使警察将他带离现场。在回警局的路上，洛佩兹承认他在奥滕西亚·加塞斯过菲卡瓦大桥时接近了她。他拿了一份报纸，对失踪女孩的头条新闻发表了评论。然后他请奥滕西亚做他的向导，提出支付十苏克雷，并买下她剩下的所有报纸。奥滕西亚同意了。洛佩兹把奥滕西亚带进河岸茂密的植被中，在那里他多次强奸了她，然后将她勒死。他在奥滕西亚的尸体旁休息了几个小时，然后把她和她的报纸埋在附近的一条
ditch. Lopez then went in search of another little girl. He couldn't find one that day, but he told police that he got lucky the next. Over the following weeks, Pedro Lopez led Captain Cordova and his office. officers to 110 remote and obscure locations across Ecuador where he claimed to have buried the bodies of his victims. None of the sites were marked, yet Lopez recalled each location with precision. At some sites, multiple bodies had been callously thrown on top of one another. At others, no bodies could be found, the remains presumably destroyed by animals, weather, and time.
沟里。洛佩兹随后去寻找另一个小女孩。那天他没找到，但他告诉警察，第二天他运气不错。在接下来的几周里，佩德罗·洛佩兹带领科尔多瓦警长和他的警官们前往厄瓜多尔各地110个偏远隐蔽的地点，他声称在那里埋葬了他的受害者。这些地点都没有标记，但洛佩兹却能精确地回忆起每一个位置。在一些地点，多具尸体被冷酷地堆叠在一起。在另一些地点，没有发现尸体，遗骸可能已被动物、天气和时间摧毁。
Construction work had since been conducted at several locations, entoming any remains under concrete. Every time a body was discovered, Lopez explained how the girl came to be there. The story was more or less always the same. Lopez would befriend his young victim and then lead her to a secluded location before raping and killing her. Eventually, Lopez told Captain Cordova, No more, I have proven enough that I am the one responsible for all the girls. In all, the bodies of 80 Ecuadorian girls were uncovered. But by Lopez's own admissions, police believed he was responsible for over 100 murders in the country.
此后，一些地点进行了施工，将任何遗骸封存在混凝土下。每发现一具尸体，洛佩兹都会解释这个女孩是如何被带到那里的。故事大同小异。洛佩兹会与年轻受害者交朋友，然后把她带到偏僻的地方，强奸并杀害她。最终，洛佩兹告诉科尔多瓦警长：“够了，我已经充分证明我是所有女孩失踪案的责任人。”总共发现了80名厄瓜多尔女孩的尸体。但根据洛佩兹自己的供述，警方认为他在该国犯下了100多起谋杀案。
The people of Ecuador weren't suffering alone. Lopez had happily admitted that he'd done the same in Colombia and Peru. Across the three countries, he claimed to have taken at least 300 lives. The realization dawned on Captain Cordova. Pedro Lopez was one of the most prolific serial killers ever known. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
厄瓜多尔人民并不是唯一的受害者。洛佩兹愉快地承认他在哥伦比亚和秘鲁也做了同样的事。他声称在这三个国家至少夺走了300条生命。科尔多瓦警长意识到，佩德罗·洛佩兹是有史以来最残暴的连环杀手之一。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。
By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. While in custody awaiting trial, Pedro Lopez was permitted to participate in media interviews. He delighted in the attention and took pleasure in detailing his story to anyone who would listen. Explaining how he chose his victims, he said, I would walk among the markets looking for a girl with a certain look on her face, a look of innocence and beauty. I like the girls of Ecuador. They are more gentle, more innocent and trusting than the girls of Colombia, who are too suspicious of strangers. Lopez admitted that the girls he targeted were victims of convenience.
通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持了“案件档案”继续提供高质量的内容。在等待审判期间，佩德罗·洛佩兹被允许接受媒体采访。他很享受这种关注，并乐于向任何愿意倾听的人详细讲述他的故事。在解释他如何选择受害者时，他说：“我会在市场上走来走去，寻找一个脸上带着某种神情的女孩，一种天真和美丽的神情。我喜欢厄瓜多尔的女孩。她们比哥伦比亚的女孩更温柔、更天真、更信任人，哥伦比亚的女孩对陌生人太警惕了。”洛佩兹承认，他针对的女孩都是随手可得的受害者。
He had often followed fair-haired children of tourists, but his own. opportunity to strike never arose as, quote, their parents were too watchful. According to Lopez, it all started in the mid-1970s following his release from prison. He spent a lot of time wandering through the mountains near the picturesque Tekandama Falls, about 30 kilometres south-west of Bogota. During one journey, he came across a young girl walking down a dirt road. She became Lopez's first child victim, and the Tekandama Falls area became a burial ground for a number of young girls thereafter. Lopez eventually made his way down to Peru, where the rapes and murders continued. In 1978, Lopez was traveling through a small village in the Ayayokucho region of southern Peru.
他经常跟踪游客的金发孩子，但自己下手的机会从未出现，因为“她们的父母太警惕了”。据洛佩兹说，这一切始于20世纪70年代中期他出狱后。他花了很多时间在波哥大西南约30公里的风景如画的特坎达马瀑布附近的群山中徘徊。在一次旅途中，他遇到了一个走在土路上的小女孩。她成了洛佩兹的第一个儿童受害者，此后特坎达马瀑布地区成了许多年轻女孩的埋骨之地。洛佩兹最终前往秘鲁，那里的强奸和谋杀仍在继续。1978年，洛佩兹在秘鲁南部阿亚库乔地区的一个小村庄旅行。
He managed to convince a nine-year-old indigenous girl to accompany him for a walk, but several Villagers saw what he was doing and quickly realized that Lopez was responsible for the spade of missing girls in the area. The community decided they would punish Lopez according to their native customs. He was stripped naked and hogtied. Honey was poured all over his body and he was thrown into a large hole. The villagers were planning to first torture Lopez with live ants and then bury him alive. Just as they were about to release the ants, an American woman stepped forward. She was a Christian missionary who had been promoting her faith in the village. The woman begged the villagers not to go through with their plan.
他设法说服一名9岁的土著女孩陪他散步，但几名村民看到了他的所作所为，很快意识到洛佩兹就是该地区一系列失踪女孩案的罪魁祸首。社区决定根据他们的本土习俗惩罚洛佩兹。他被剥光衣服，手脚被捆在一起。蜂蜜被倒在他全身，然后他被扔进一个大坑里。村民们计划先用活蚂蚁折磨洛佩兹，然后将他活埋。就在他们准备释放蚂蚁时，一名美国妇女站了出来。她是一位在该村传教的基督教传教士。这位妇女恳求村民们不要执行他们的计划。
She urged them to let her deliver Lopez to the Peruvian authorities instead. The villagers agreed. Lopez was hauled into the woman's jeep and driven to the region's police station. But the Peruvian police were apathetic to the plight of indigenous communities, and they had no interest in investigating Lopez's involvement with the missing girls. Without so much as questioning him, they escorted Lopez across the border and released him back into Colombia. Lopez estimated that by the time he left Peru in 1978, he had murdered over 100 girls there.
她敦促他们让她把洛佩兹交给秘鲁当局。村民们同意了。洛佩兹被拖进那名妇女的吉普车，带到了该地区的警察局。但秘鲁警察对土著社区的困境漠不关心，他们对调查洛佩兹与失踪女孩案的关联毫无兴趣。他们甚至没有审问他，就将洛佩兹押送过境，并将他释放回哥伦比亚。洛佩兹估计，到1978年他离开秘鲁时，他在那里已经谋杀了100多名女孩。
He claimed to have spent the next year travelling along the Andes mountain range between Colombia and Ecuador, abducting, raping and strangling young girls with impunity. Based on the number of burial locations that Pedro Lopez had pinpointed to Ecuadorian police, he was eventually charged with the rape and murder of 110 girls. In July 1981, 14 months after his capture, Lopez faced the judge. Despite his previous confessions, and for reasons unknown, he pleaded guilty to only 57 of those charges. Lopez labelled himself the man of the century, while the people of Ecuador called him the monster of the Andes.
他声称在接下来的一年里，他沿着哥伦比亚和厄瓜多尔之间的安第斯山脉旅行，肆无忌惮地绑架、强奸和勒死年轻女孩。根据佩德罗·洛佩兹向厄瓜多尔警方指出的埋尸地点数量，他最终被控强奸和谋杀110名女孩。1981年7月，在他被捕14个月后，洛佩兹面对法官。尽管他之前有过供述，但出于未知原因，他只对其中57项指控认罪。洛佩兹自称为“世纪之子”，而厄瓜多尔人民则称他为“安第斯山的怪物”。
The general consensus was that Lopez deserved nothing short of execution, but the death penalty had been abolished in Ecuador 70 years prior. The revulsion against Lopez's crimes was so great that a mass protest was staged in Umpato. The families of the young victims petitioned the president to allow the death penalty in this instance, commenting. Our hearts are bloodied and our hands are raised to heaven imploring justice. The president acknowledged the pain that the families and all Ecuadorians were feeling, but rejected the request. Instead, he asked them to put their trust in the justice system, assuring that Lopez would be punished to the full extent of the law.
普遍的共识是洛佩兹罪有应得，理应处死，但厄瓜多尔在70年前就废除了死刑。对洛佩兹罪行的厌恶感如此强烈，以至于安巴托爆发了大规模抗议。年轻受害者的家属请愿总统在此案中允许执行死刑，并评论道：“我们的心在滴血，我们的双手举向天空祈求正义。”总统承认了家属和所有厄瓜多尔人感受到的痛苦，但拒绝了这一请求。相反，他要求他们信任司法系统，并保证洛佩兹将受到法律的全面制裁。
Ecuador's criminal code did not permit sentences for murder to run consecutively. Accordingly, Pedro Lopez would only be sentenced for one murder, not the dozens he had pleaded guilty to, nor the potential hundreds he was responsible for. Lopez was given the maximum penalty for murder that was in force in Ecuador at the time. 16 years. Just over 13 years later, on Wednesday, August 31, 1994, Pedro Lopez was released from prison early on account of good behavior. He was 45 years old. However, Lopez was considered an illegal immigrant in Ecuador.
厄瓜多尔的刑法不允许谋杀罪的刑期连续执行。因此，佩德罗·洛佩兹只能因一起谋杀案被判刑，而不是他认罪的几十起，更不是他可能负责的数百起。洛佩兹被判处了当时厄瓜多尔法律规定的最高谋杀刑罚：16年。13年多后，即1994年8月31日星期三，佩德罗·洛佩兹因表现良好提前获释。他当时45岁。然而，洛佩兹在厄瓜多尔被视为非法移民。
As soon as he was released, he was immediately taken into custody by immigration officials. The following day, he was escorted across the border and delivered to the Colombian authorities. It was the moment they'd been waiting for for 14 years. In late December 1979, two months prior to Lopez's capture in Ecuador, a nine-year-old girl named Flores Sanchez went missing from the Colombian town of El Espinall. Shortly after, Floor's body was discovered. She had been raped and strangled. Over the following weeks, the bodies of four more girls were discovered in Andean towns leading south back towards Ecuador. At the time, Colombian authorities had no idea who was responsible for the murders.
他一获释，就立即被移民官员拘留。第二天，他被押送过境并移交给哥伦比亚当局。这是他们等待了14年的时刻。1979年12月下旬，即洛佩兹在厄瓜多尔被捕前两个月，一名叫弗洛雷斯·桑切斯的9岁女孩在哥伦比亚的埃尔埃斯皮纳尔镇失踪。不久之后，弗洛雷斯的尸体被发现。她被强奸并勒死。在接下来的几周里，又有四名女孩的尸体在通往厄瓜多尔的安第斯城镇中被发现。当时，哥伦比亚当局根本不知道是谁制造了这些谋杀案。
After Pedro Lopez was captured in Ecuador, the reality became clear. El Espinall was Lopez's hometown. Floor Sanchez had gone missing the day after Pedro Lopez arrived for a visit there. He left town a few days later, traveling his usual route south along the Andes. In media interviews following his capture, Lopez boasted about committing many murders in El Espinal. He was amused that the police hadn't found more bodies. With Pedro Lopez back on Colombian soil, authorities were finally able to charge him with the murder of Floor Sanchez. In Colombia, the maximum penalty for murder was 60 years. Given Lopez was 45, 60 years would effectively be a life sentence.
佩德罗·洛佩兹在厄瓜多尔被捕后，真相大白。埃斯皮纳尔是洛佩兹的家乡。弗洛尔·桑切斯就是在佩德罗·洛佩兹去那里探亲后的第二天失踪的。几天后他离开了小镇，沿着安第斯山脉向南走他惯常的路线。在被捕后的媒体采访中，洛佩兹吹嘘自己在埃斯皮纳尔犯下了多起谋杀案。他觉得警察没能发现更多尸体很有趣。随着佩德罗·洛佩兹回到哥伦比亚，当局终于能够以谋杀弗洛尔·桑切斯的罪名起诉他。在哥伦比亚，谋杀罪的最高刑罚是60年。考虑到洛佩兹当时45岁，60年实际上就是终身监禁。
This gave comfort to the families of Lopez's victims, who felt cheated by the leniency of Ecuador's justice system. But such comfort was short-lived. As part of the pretrial procedures, Lopez was subjected to a psychiatric examination. He was deemed mentally ill and therefore not criminally responsible for his actions. Lopez had consistently described a childhood of abuse and trauma. He claimed that his mother was a sex worker, that he never knew his own father, and that all of his siblings were father. by different men.
这让洛佩兹受害者的家属感到一丝安慰，他们曾因厄瓜多尔司法系统的宽大处理而感到被欺骗。但这种安慰是短暂的。作为审前程序的一部分，洛佩兹接受了精神病检查。他被认定患有精神疾病，因此不对自己的行为承担刑事责任。洛佩兹一直描述自己有一个充满虐待和创伤的童年。他声称他的母亲是一名性工作者，他从未见过自己的亲生父亲，而且他所有的兄弟姐妹都是不同男人的孩子。
As a child, Lopez claimed that his mother was violent and abusive towards him, kicking him out of the family home when he was just eight years old. He spent the rest of his childhood on the streets. Lopez recalled he'd once been taken in by a seemingly kind man who turned out to be a pedophile. He escaped and returned to the streets. A few years later, when Lopez was 12, an American couple took pity on him. They gave him food and clothes and enrolled him in school. There, Lopez claimed he was sexually abused by one of the teachers.
洛佩兹声称，小时候母亲对他暴力相向，在他八岁时就把他赶出了家门。他的童年余下时光都在街头度过。洛佩兹回忆说，他曾被一个看似善良的男人收留，结果那人是个恋童癖。他逃了出来，又回到了街头。几年后，当洛佩兹12岁时，一对美国夫妇同情他。他们给了他食物和衣服，并送他去上学。洛佩兹声称在那里遭到了其中一名老师的性虐待。
According to Lopez, the rapes and murders he committed were in retaliation for his own childhood. He told the media, I lost my innocence at the age of eight, and I decided to do the same to as many young girls as possible. I am not sorry for what I did. After Lopez's psychological assessment was handed down in Columbia, the psychiatric community debated his mental state. Some believed that Lopez was turned into a rapist and killer by his childhood experiences. Others believed he was a born psychopath. incapable of remorse or rehabilitation.
据洛佩兹说，他犯下的强奸和谋杀案是对他自己童年的报复。他告诉媒体：“我在八岁时失去了纯真，我决定让尽可能多的年轻女孩也经历同样的事情。我不为我所做的一切感到抱歉。”在哥伦比亚对洛佩兹进行心理评估后，精神病学界对他的精神状态进行了辩论。一些人认为洛佩兹是被童年经历变成了强奸犯和杀人犯。另一些人则认为他是一个天生的精神病态者，无法悔改或改造。
Instead of a life behind bars, he was sent to a mental health facility for ongoing treatment. Just over three years later, in February 1998, Pedro Lopez was declared cured and sane. At the age of 49 years, he walked out of the facility a free man. The first thing Lopez did was travel to El Espinal, to see his mother, Benilda. In the years since Lopez had been captured, Benilda had been interviewed several times. She rejected her son's claims of child abuse,
他没有被关进监狱，而是被送往一家精神卫生机构接受持续治疗。三年多后的1998年2月，佩德罗·洛佩兹被宣布治愈并神志清醒。49岁那年，他走出了该机构，重获自由。洛佩兹做的第一件事就是前往埃斯皮纳尔看望他的母亲贝尼尔达。在洛佩兹被捕后的几年里，贝尼尔达曾多次接受采访。她否认了儿子关于虐待儿童的说法，
saying that although their family was poor and life wasn't easy, theirs had always been a loving home. Benilda claimed she made her living as a laundress, not a sex worker. She clarified that Lopez's father had died six months before Lopolde, was born, having been killed during Colombia's civil violence. According to Benilda, Lopez grew angry and resentful after she remarried and had children with her new husband. He wasn't kicked out of home, but had left on his own accord. He returned
她说，虽然他们家很穷，生活也不容易，但他们的家一直充满爱。贝尼尔达声称她是以洗衣为生，而不是性工作者。她澄清说，洛佩兹的父亲在洛佩兹出生前六个月就去世了，是在哥伦比亚的内战暴力中丧生的。据贝尼尔达说，洛佩兹在她再婚并与新丈夫生下孩子后变得愤怒和怨恨。他不是被赶出家门的，而是自愿离开的。他回来时
at the age of 18, at which point Benilda caught him inappropriately touching his younger sisters and kicked him out. Benilda said her son was a disgrace to society. If she had known what he was capable of, she said she would have killed him herself to save humanity from his crimes. She expressed her deep apologies to the families of his victims, whom she lit a candle for every day. Benilda had no desire to see her son again.
是在18岁那年，当时贝尼尔达发现他对他年幼的妹妹们有不当的触摸行为，于是把他赶了出去。贝尼尔达说她的儿子是社会的耻辱。她说，如果她早知道他有这种能力，她会亲手杀了他，以拯救人类免受他的罪行伤害。她向受害者的家属表达了深深的歉意，她每天都为他们点燃蜡烛。贝尼尔达再也不想见到她的儿子了。
When Lopez arrived at her door after being released from the mental health facility, it wasn't for a family reunion. He wanted money. Benilda was still very poor and had nothing to give. Instead, Lopez took some of her furniture and sold it for a meager amount of cash. He left El Espinall and faded back into the Andes. In the years that followed, other young girls between the ages of 7 and 14 went missing along the mountain range. Of those who were found deceased, some had suffered the same fate as Pedro Lopez's previous victims.
当洛佩兹从精神卫生机构获释来到她家门口时，并不是为了家庭团聚。他是来要钱的。贝尼尔达依然很穷，没有什么可给的。于是，洛佩兹拿走了她的一些家具，以微薄的价格卖掉。他离开了埃斯皮纳尔，消失在安第斯山脉中。在随后的几年里，其他年龄在7到14岁之间的年轻女孩沿着山脉失踪了。在那些被发现死亡的人中，有些人遭受了与佩德罗·洛佩兹之前的受害者相同的命运。
He immediately became a suspect. Not only did the crimes fit his MO, there were serious doubts that he could ever be rehabilitated. Lopez had been proud of his crimes, and at no point had he ever shown a hint of remorse. Lopez had once told the Ecuadorian police, quote, The moment of death is passionate and exciting. Someday, when I'm free, I'll feel that moment again. I will be happy to kill again. It is my mission.
他立即成为了嫌疑人。这些罪行不仅符合他的作案手法，而且人们严重怀疑他是否能被改造。洛佩兹一直为自己的罪行感到自豪，并且从未表现出丝毫悔意。洛佩兹曾告诉厄瓜多尔警方：“死亡的那一刻是激情而令人兴奋的。总有一天，当我自由时，我会再次感受到那一刻。我很乐意再次杀人。这是我的使命。”
In 2002, Interpol issued a warrant for Pedro Lopez's arrest, but he couldn't be located. Family members of his victims had been vocal about their desire. for revenge. Some had threatened to shoot Lopez, others to burn him alive. The mother of one young victim had told reporters, I wanted to break him into pieces because he killed my baby. Carlina Ramon, the market vendor who captured Lopez near Plaza Robina, supported the intention, stating, it would be a kindness to the world for someone to murder the this fiend. Many believe that someone did just that. As of mid-2023, Pedro Lopez has never been found alive. If he is still alive, Lopez would be in his mid-70s. Back in 1980, when Pedro
2002年，国际刑警组织对佩德罗·洛佩兹发出了逮捕令，但他无法被定位。受害者的家属们一直大声疾呼他们想要复仇。有些人威胁要枪杀洛佩兹，另一些人则威胁要将他活活烧死。一名年轻受害者的母亲曾告诉记者：“我想把他碎尸万段，因为他杀死了我的孩子。”在罗比纳广场附近抓获洛佩兹的市场小贩卡琳娜·拉蒙支持这一意图，称：“如果有人能杀了这个恶魔，那将是对世界的一种仁慈。”许多人认为确实有人这么做了。截至2023年中期，佩德罗·洛佩兹从未被发现活着。如果他还活着，洛佩兹现在应该70多岁了。早在1980年，当佩德罗
Lopez led Ecuadorian police to his burial sites, the remains of his victims were transported to the Umbato police headquarters. Parents of missing girls, travelled from across the country to view one corpse after another. For many, a visual identification wasn't possible. Instead, grief-stricken mothers and fathers clutched familiar items of clothing and wept over bones. Some mothers screamed and passed out, while languished fathers punched walls. Captain Pastor Cordova would never forget watching the heartbreaking procession of grieving parents. Years later, he described it as, The most painful thing I've ever seen in my life. Nearly half of the victims uncovered by
洛佩兹带领厄瓜多尔警方前往他的埋尸地点时，受害者的遗体被运往翁巴托警察总部。失踪女孩的父母从全国各地赶来，一具接一具地辨认尸体。对许多人来说，视觉辨认是不可能的。相反，悲痛欲绝的母亲和父亲紧紧抓住熟悉的衣物，在白骨前痛哭。一些母亲尖叫着昏倒，而痛苦的父亲们则捶打着墙壁。帕斯托·科尔多瓦队长永远不会忘记看着这群悲伤的父母走过那令人心碎的队伍。多年后，他将其描述为：“我一生中见过的最痛苦的事情。”近一半被发现的受害者
police could not be identified. If Lopez's confessions are to be relied on, potentially hundreds more in Colombia and Peru remain lost and buried. The true number and identities of the missing girls of the Andes will likely never be. known. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
警方无法确认身份。如果洛佩兹的供词可信，那么在哥伦比亚和秘鲁可能还有数百人失踪并被埋葬。安第斯山脉失踪女孩的真实人数和身份可能永远不会为人所知。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。